[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Falcon and Winter Soldier
Super Bowl trailer breakdown there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs for the
Captain America comics for all the
Captain America movies a lot of
callbacks to Avengers and game and
Marvel phase four stuff that they're
setting up so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing that infinity
saga box set giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be subscriber and leave all
your theories about what this sets up
just like during my one division trailer
video because they break a lot of this
footage up in a really nonlinear way
I'll try to break it down
chronologically the way I think it
happens through the episodes a couple
big things to point out the main villain
of this series is going to be Baron Zemo
obviously he's going full comic book
Baron Zemo because he's got the purple
mask in the preview that they showed off
at d23 just like one division this
series takes place after the Avengers
end game ending where old man Captain
America returned to our timeline after
living out his life with Peggy Carter
after I might add he returned all the
Infinity stones to the places in times
they stole them from and took Thor's
hammer back to Asgard he pulls a fast
one on him shows up on that bench and
then gives his shield and basically
passes the mantle to Falcon says try it
on it's meant to be sort of a metaphor
like try on the mantle of Captain
America at some point for those of you
asking if old man Captain America is
gonna have a cameo seen during the
Falcon and Winter Soldier episodes this
is what Chris Evans said about it when
he was asked because obviously people
are like are you gonna show up during
this at some point because even though
you're an old man you're still alive
you're still around and this version of
Earth he said it would be kind of weird
to rush old man cap out of retirement
and that he Chris Evans in real life had
also kind of just retired at least
temporarily from the Marvel movies he
didn't say he would never come back but
he said that they ended on such a great
moment that why would they want to take
that back so I don't think he's lying or
anything I don't think he filmed any new
scenes for Falcon in Winter Soldier but
I think that they'll spend a lot of time
referencing Captain America and old man
cap during the series so it will invoke
him in a really big way
my assumption just based on what the
Russos and Chris Evans said is that
after this scene here old man cap
quietly retired to a house somewhere is
being kept under watchful eye by both
his surviving Avengers friends who are
trying to take care of him and
Thunderbolt Ross in the military who
want to keep tabs on him Thunderbolt
Ross is very important to the Falcon and
Winter Soldier
Cirie's even though he doesn't show up
anywhere in this trailer the trailer
itself opens with the bumping sound like
a heartbeat in the shot opens up on
Captain America's shield which is
embedded in a tree as Falcon practises
throwing it on what looks like some
remote house maybe it belongs to Falcons
family or something like that they're
just hiding out somewhere trying to
figure out what they're gonna do next
the way the shot opens up to top to
bottom is kind of like someone opening
their eyes but then they play the
regular Marvel Studios logo which
switches to a blue logo obviously blue
the color of the Disney Plus interface
just letting everyone know who doesn't
follow Marvel news that this is the same
it's the same people that make the
movies that are making this Disney Plus
series it's the same movie actors so
it's meant to be the same continuous
story just in a slightly different
format it's meant to be a little bit
special then there's a scene of Falcon
in his new red wingsuit in the canyons
trying to take down this group of
wingsuit gliders in yellow and black who
turn around mid-flight to try and shoot
him down the big Easter Egg here that
you may have recognized is that these
villains are wearing classic comic book
Hydra colors that doesn't confirm that
they're still left over Hydra operatives
running around everywhere that they have
to take down Baron Zemo is meant to be
the main villain but he'll probably be
trying to exploit every weakness he can
every opportunity and since they're
pulling out a lot of comic book deep
cuts from the Captain America comics
Baron Zemo has been involved in most of
the major evil organizations from Marvel
Comics history including Hydra then
there's a scene of Winter Soldier acting
like he really wants to kill Zemo who's
wearing his classic comic-book outfit
including the purple mask that we saw
during d23 but he stops himself for some
reason as you see the bullets of his gun
falling through the fingers of his
vibranium hand thank you very much black
panther and Sheree for that vibranium
arm this is a big callback to the events
of Captain America Civil Wars emo
exploited then framed Winter Soldier for
a bunch of killings that exposed his
past assassination of iron man's parents
during the early 90s then went on to try
and turn the remnants of the Hydra super
soldiers against the Avengers in a bid
to tear them apart successfully remember
his whole goal during that movie was to
tear the Avengers apart so technically
he beat them that was what that whole
ending with Everett Ross was about where
Everett Ross is trying to lord it over
him like we beat you we stopped you
before
you were able to accomplish her goal and
he's like did you really though I kind
of did exactly what I set out to do the
avengers just tore themselves apart even
though they eventually did get back
together during avengers endgame in part
of the whole idea of Winter Soldier
after the events of Avengers endgame
after being brought back after getting
snapped is that he wants to clear the
red from his ledger black widow style
just like she did and killings emo
wouldn't solve that
Zemo probably knows that and tries to
use it against him then there's this big
new scene of the government's new fake
version of Captain America John Walker
aka u.s. agent think of him as the
darker version of Captain America who
Thunderbolt Ross in the US military
select is their replacement for old man
cap you have to keep in mind the Captain
America hung up the shield so to speak
he retired but the government loves the
concept of Captain America so much as a
figure to rally the troops around rally
support from the American people
so they want another Captain America
that they can use that for but they want
their own man who's on their payroll who
will do what they say you could just see
old man cap shouting at the TV watching
this broadcast how dare you stand where
I stood look at the a symbols on this
marching band here at this big football
game is almost like Thunderbolt Ross is
trying to hijack the legacy of Captain
America and the Avengers for their own
purposes like look this is our version
the government's version of the Avengers
in Captain America everyone embraced
them just all kinds are wrong on all
kinds of levels I've already done a
video for that first look teaser for a
US agents new Captain America suit in
his backstory a while ago but just like
in the comics he's the more hardcore
version of Captain America like you see
him standing here in his dress uniform
it looks like maybe he was injured in a
recent war or a conflict and then they
give him some derivative of the Super
Soldier Serum that turns him into their
version of Captain America remember way
back during the Incredible Hulk
Thunderbolt Ross had a special
quote-unquote program that he was
experimenting with the Super Soldier
Serum he gave that to the abomination
which set him on the path to eventually
becoming the comic book abomination so
he probably just revives that program to
create the new version of Captain
America then there's the scene of Falcon
and Winter Soldier in a hallway that
either looks like a military base or a
prison maybe maybe it has something to
do with Baron Zemo Winter Soldier looks
more pissed off than Falcon for whatever
reason there's also a bunch of images
from the set this is what winter
soldiers two new other comic book
costumes are going to look like he has
multiple costumes during the series you
also get a much better look at his
vibranium arm these are both meant to be
versions of suits that he wore in the
comics the cool thing though that we
haven't talked about is the other secret
abilities that his vibranium arm has
Kevin Feige teased way back at d23 that
winter soldiers vibranium arm has a lot
of special weaponry built into it just
like all vibranium gear that Shuri
designs they just never had the time to
show it off during avengers endgame my
early guess is that it just has a lot of
the similar abilities that Black
Panthers costume has like he can absorb
energy through it and then redirect it
they'll probably released the next big
Falcon and Winter Soldier trailer in May
when Black Widow comes out and maybe
they'll have some finished special
effects to show off the whole idea of
the series is that Zemo escapes prison
and sets off this worldwide terror plan
that Falcon and Winter Soldier had to
team up to stop while also fending off
the US government and Thunderbolt Ross
who don't want Falcon to have caps
shield Anthony Mackie did say back at
d23 he would not be taking Captain
America's name though he would always
still be called Falcon regardless of
what his costume looks like and whether
or not he holds the shield all the
Thunderbolts stuff is sort of a darker
twisted version of the Avenger set up
remember the way they seated all the
Avengers buildup in the first Marvel
phase 1 movies they're using Thunderbolt
Ross to do a version of that with all
the Marvel phase 4 stuff so that'll
start with the Black Widow movie I think
we all have some expectations about
post-credit scenes but we can talk about
that more when we get more Black Widow
footage Lillian Nick Fury director of
shield I'm here to talk to you about the
Avenger initiative she's not anywhere in
the footage but Sharon Carter is also
one of the main characters in the series
probably still working with Thunderbolt
Ross in the world Security Council and
there's probably a whole bunch of other
deep cut characters from the Captain
America comics that we won't find out
about till they actually drop the
episodes they did start implying that
some of these Disney Plus Marvel series
will get future seasons one division
will probably only be one see
but they're already talking about doing
Loki's season - and they might do the
same thing with Falcon and Winter
Soldier right now the release date is
gonna be sometime at the end of August
after Comic Con there'll be six episodes
total I will do a video for the Loki
trailer there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and stuff that they set up in a
really cosmic multiverse way in that so
all the Disney Plus series will be very
very different so the stuff that's
happening on whan division will be very
different from what they're doing on
Falcon a Winter Soldier will be very
Loki everyone post all your theories
about Falcon and Winter Soldier in the
comments below let me know how you think
this sets up Thunderbolts because that's
obviously a big part of the series we
probably won't see a whole lot of that
happening during the trailers though
everyone click here for my brand new
Wanda vision Super Bowl trailer and
click here for that new black widow
Super Bowl trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome this is
the way
[Music]